he's like two breasts like know what
your head in between the breasts
we have been a couple for two years by a
year almost two years three years four
years
this is gonna be weirdly sexual I think
is this a sex ring
no it just covers up those rough like
bony edges like two breasts like know
what your head in between the breasts I
like my dog would just hump it I'm
supposed to put my face on that picture
I know they're cuddling to 6090 I think
it's like this that come in here I
thought this is like entrapment um
doesn't hurt not yet how is that awful
there's a yes product I'm mixed I'm
gonna say no smitten walking mittens for
friends and lovers I just threw up in my
mouth just a little bit it's kind of
cute long as you never go out in public
what's your hand in this big bed but I
need my hands at all yeah she does she's
very expressive I like this for in the
house cuz my hands are always breathing
yeah but then like your hands are gonna
start sweating on the inside like an
oven yeah it's pretty moist
I'm already it's not really that
convenient I feel like this is what you
do in pockets I would absolutely not buy
this is the no this is a yes we're not
this is not how we roll Mickey Mouse
hands are pointing at your vagina
so that's comforting oh yeah that's
vulgar oh I think I might get it now no
it's not like if some girls started
getting up all um then I think it's okay
I just don't I just I just don't touch
the day I would rather you every time we
pass a female for you to go that's mine
that's mine than to wear this now this
is a maybe No
what the is this no no hell no this is
like a big body condom I'm confused
about how much time you would actually
spend in like cuz you put them on uh I
can't wait to get in those panties
literally stand up you know on second
thought that's my knob you be worth it I
think a lot of these things we're just
reaching like if you have a good
relationship like we know how we cuddle
we know how we like to get things going
I don't need weird underwear and pillow
to tell me how to do it it kind of
brought us together in ways you didn't
expect I think if your girlfriend likes
these products and you don't it could
possibly be a red flag or a Reds mitten
[Music]